entrance was by ticket only and among
the fighters on the bill were
eight-year-old boys racing against the
side control after seeing the footage
one person alerted the police but the
event breached no licensing regulations
and is within the law but the boys were
not wearing protective headgear or pads
and at one point one of the schoolboy
fighters is seen to break down in tears
I mean this is the one danger that
you've got with juniors is that you know
they can be gallant and games became
despite widespread condemnation one
father told us he was completely happy
for his nine-year-old son kid to take
part he does it himself nobody forces
him to do it he gets asked as you want
to do it and he says yeah I'll do it
so nobody forces him and I can't stop
him if he wants to do enjoys doing
something then let him go ahead and do
it you know when you get into the cage
what what's he feeling when you're going
into the cage what just describe that
for us excited and what do you like
about it
the British Medical Association
described the event in Preston as
particularly disturbing as the children
were not wearing head gear the NSPCC
joined in the criticism saying that at
the age of eight children's bodies were
still developing physically and mentally
the British Cagefighting Association
said it was totally against the
participation of children it said this
is disgusting and any parent that allows
their child to cage fight must be a
[ __ ] but one of the trainers in Preston
says people have misunderstood it's
people in
hormon in on the fat base cage this cage
that's a mixed martial arts
demonstration
they did two three-minute rounds with
noir winner they both got a trophy at
the end there was a professional referee
we but like profession
medical staff it was you know every
precaution was taken well this is the
spot where the cage fighting took place
before an audience of about 200 people
but despite the criticism that they
faced here at the Greenland's New Labour
Club today
they say that they fully intend to stage
another similar event in a few months
time so you know Lucas Lancashire police
have investigated the event but have
taken no further action as the activity
is completely legal Mike McCarthy Sky
News Preston